it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay
there you go there you go there's your
so I do this with my left right and then
I
ho hello everybody my name is marbl and
welcome back to Five Night at Freddy's
Help Wanted oh my God I'm
great am I not supposed to shoot those
hold on get my eye
in nope not quite ah shoot wait that was
a Target wasn't it hold
on that's what you
get hold on oh yeah that's what I'm
talking about
okay oh boy
[Music]
hey hold on no I got to keep it this way
that's what I've trained
for I'm starving who what what' you say
who said that oh I'm doing great I'm
starving
was it was it you
chica oh
yeah damn it this is actually quite
tough out of
there oh did I get it oh I'm doing great
anyway
okay I got did you really
oh thank you
oh you should have known I'd find you go
away whoop oh boy hold on wait a minute
that's not oh what do you mean
oh oh oh oh oh what was that what was
that
hey what do you
mean you can't do something like
that what do you mean what what do you
mean what hey oh stop
that what are you doing get away what
are you doing don't do
that I'm
starving oh
man oh come
on oh come on who did that I heard
that come
on huh there you
are oh man go get your prize go get my
prize okay thank you
okay well I did that and it was
moderately more stressful but not
terribly so feel like it's been a while
since I got one of
these Tron the gang okay so I know it's
been a bit since I was playing this and
we have just a few more levels to go
before where's trash in the game where
are
you where are
you hi hello well that's good so I I
actually think I just have one more
cuz all these other ones are virused up
I just have the music time too
everything else has been gotten I still
technically have this here but I don't
have a coin and I don't think I have any
on my person and I can't exactly do
anything about that because as far as I
know doesn't that take the AR off
doesn't this obliterate the whole VR
thing
oh listen listen to me how was I
supposed to know that that's how that
was done because in you know ruin you
didn't have to grab it so it it's not
entirely my fault that's that's a little
dumb I'm a little dumb but it seems like
everything okay anyway cuz these are
still broken so I don't know what that
did but I do have just one more to go
don't let the mini music man get too
close use the Faz cam listen matches
beats exactly use a visualizer and
replay it again as you needed okay all
right so I just got the added bonus if
I've got little guys Crawling After me
but I can take care of
that oh that was
me oh my God okay five
rounds J that's what you get God damn
look at you Majestic as all hell yeah
come
closer yeah you like
that hello I'm ready give me the
beats
I hear the little
FL
hey oh man I don't
[Music]
remember hey was that oh wait a minute
hold on there hang on I got to hear it
again ah
green
green and it was something else I think
that was it wasn't that it or was the
hills different were the hills different
I think the hills might have been
different okay that's a little
rude uh mountains okay I think the only
way to get through that is just to look
at it because it's really hard to
discern what the individual not that
there you
go uh
chica thank
[Music]
you Rainbow Man
okay
done crocodil
whatever his name
Monty thank
you blue blue blue blue blue blue
rainbows got
it whoa my God oh my God okay blue blue
blue blue blue blue
rainbows how did you get
there what's up Moon I don't like
that thank you green pink blue green
pink
blue
green where are
you whoa oh my
God always the rainbow
Freddy was that Freddy uh oh wait a
minute no did I did I did
I oh okay that's what I was about to
say okay green blue green blue
star
Mario
green
blue
star Bo w
w
hi yay I did it well that wasn't too
much of a
threat all right so now I've done all of
the things that I can do right now
right oh that's I I don't I don't
actually want that so that I've done all
the things and then I've put down the
little transmitter thing that should oh
well let me just check real quick not
100% sure what
I'm oh
Bonnie Bonnie thank you Bonnie okay
but
wait oh so he is here
good I I needed that in my life and also
loose
here you're not moving are you okay good
okay so let me check to see something's
going on over here I still don't have a
coin but that's down hey hippo you going
to give me any kind of a
clue no clue can I get a clue okie dokie
uh well I'm now confused because I don't
have anything else these are locked
those are broken these are done they're
they're all bunned up what exactly am I
missing right got to be something
because I I got all the coins but I
don't know where they went did I not get
enough have I not gotten enough of them
in all the other levels to be able to
progress how wait where did the wrench
go
wrench
wrench oh my god did I do
that I thought you were about to betray
me I didn't know I'd miss head chef bot
hi okay so if I use my big big brain
I've gotten these things right oh God
how can I grab that so I have these
things right and if I think about this
there's got to be something that I can
do with these things otherwise why would
they give them to
me oh God oh my God so there's some
things that are physically Interactive
I can't have that ah it's gone so why is
that physically
interactable oh I I can pick it why can
I pick this up wh why is this something
that I can pick
up why would this be something that I
can pick up this is very
strange why why do I have
this why why do I need this you go there
yes all right let me think about this
clearly I haven't gotten enough coins
because if I did have enough coins then
I wouldn't have anything to worry about
and I know there's a coin in bora's
gallery up on the thing but I was too
impatient to get it but that doesn't
mean I can't get it it just means I'm
really impatient let me try that again
just a little is someone there not at
all
malam that's my lady ma'am I'm going to
go the long
[Music]
just a mouse just a tiny
[Applause]
[Music]
little I'm guessing that being quiet is
part of this
experience someone is
inside
uhoh up okay can't move when you're
dancing I get it I'm not 100% sure what
the way around because it seems like
they're defending the outer
walls but if I had to guess for your
safety please make
your maybe I just got to be really fast
I I might be able to outrun those things
the speediest mouse you ever seen
someone is inside
[Music]
nuh all right that's not
working I'm going to go ahead and say it
that's not working if that could work
then it would work this got to be a coin
up there right there wouldn't not be a
coin up there that would be illogical
and dumb but but I'm going to come back
to that because I'm not going to bash my
head against the wall on something just
yet I'm going to see if there's
something else here that has a coin I'm
probably all of these has a coin so I'm
going to go from I think I got one in
the Arts and Crafts got all day I know I
know do you think all this just happens
uh no I actually know for a fact that I
do most of it and uh it's very
ungrateful uh-huh yeah uh-huh go on have
you seen a coin you got a coin anywhere
on you
you got a coin anywhere on you where's
the coin hm where where's the coin
what's behind your ear doink what's
behind your ear doink that would have
been amazing if that was the case hold
on purse there you
go eyes eyes eyes eyes eyes eyes eyes
eyes eyes eyes eyes all right well I
didn't see any coins there this is
strange
Maybe
wait a minute is that a
clue
oh
uhoh
[Music]
sad
oh
well this place has certainly seen
better days but then again so have I
come get your candy here candy candy can
can candy uh uhhuh now I will tell you a
story all right about a family that
missed the most important opportunity in
their lives
uh-huh
oh it was a limited time offer that
included a family style pizza with all
their favorite topings
uhhuh it also came with a side of
thrives mozarella sticks extra large
soft drinks a toy
surprise uhhuh it was only
$49.99 while supplies
lasted uhhuh they did not purchase the
food and they all
died oh good story now let me tell you a
story about a young woman who when she
was little was led into a dark Forest by
a witch and almost
eaten uhhuh I'm captain at she had
fallen for the friendly Voice without
discernment and once LED astray she had
escaped before being thrown into the
oven but would have a scar for the rest
of her
life H oh
oh okay well this was um enlightening I
don't know if that was a clue for the
food or
what there was a lot of stuff going on
but I don't know of a way to repeat
them
right oh no my friends have been
obliviated well this is
oh oh hi guys up there this is good this
is very good okay
well we
oh huh okay Fazbear theater okay uh-huh
first aid scrap baby I don't want to
administer first aid to scrap
baby I don't want to do
that bonab Bon I hurt myself with that
one DJ Time pro and still some unlocked
ones Cinder Carousel
2 breaker room hard reset office Puppet
Master great this is all really fun well
you know we were just there help Roxy is
having a fashion Emer see help Roxy get
ready for her performance match the
right makeup and accessories whatever
you do don't let Roxy get too angry pay
attention to her use the Roxy talkie to
calm her
down thought I could just give soothing
words I'm very soothing holy sh [__]
right
now nobody will like me fix me I look
horrible oh my god oh oh look at me I am
oh I am oh I am okay all right well this
is going to this is this we need a
little bit of uh Tada oh better
already okay all right and this is okay
yeah that's yeah oh boy oh boy at I know
I know can I borrow these for a second
thank
you oh no no no it's okay sweet l boy
sweet l boy
you you you
are it's okay oh God am I on like a is
this like the end oh God okay I need you
need an eyeball okay you need how about
this how about this how about this it's
okay it's okay it's okay it's okay it's
okay it's okay it's okay there you go
there you go there you go
R all right
um well she seems a
little touchy my God how bad is it be
honest well it's been worse and I know
it could be worse hi uh good to see you
uh how have you been
H lips and cheek you got it boink yeah
that's oh yeah oh better already
instantaneously better how about on of
these to Adorn and then you want the
eyes with the weird ribs in them look I
am well that's not an eyeball I don't
think that's an eyeball okay one eye
with ribs there you go that's that's
what you ordered I am looking at you
you're
[Music]
ready no no no no oh whoopsies no no
it's okay are you are beauty is forever
beauty is forever you heard me and I'm
always right beauty is forever and you
are Beauty what a beauty you got it yep
absolutely on the right okay so it does
say you need need some kind of a yeah
this
old
beautiful hi it's whoa it's me okay hold
on
sleepy time red yep of
course no no no no no no no no sweet
L the sweetest L Bo at this one yeah I
got you won and you're
ready
no okay you need a fluttery left yes
fluttery left W fluttery left there you
go oh it's okay don't worry about that
me I will of course I'll I'll gladly
look at you and I am looking at you I
just need to know pay attention yes of
course lips and the te look at me yes I
am hold on let me get that
eye love you and all that you
do I am FK and then some some of your
own blush to really bring out your eyes
okay I'm looking at you do you really
want want this one is this that really
okay yeah that's what you want okay and
then a spatula on the right it's what
the doctor
ordered isn't that it isn't isn't that
oh oh God you're right you're so
right all right one more oh my God J ah
well that's a problem hold on uh I'm I
I'm I'm in a bad spot hold on to me
though this is wrong this is all wrong
oh God I'm trying to Center that's not
right either how is this correct that's
not right okay we'll do we'll make it
work we'll make it work we'll make it
work just like we'll make you work cuz
right now it doesn't let me tell you
that this this is not working for
anybody but once I'm done with you oh my
God people won't be saying that in shock
they'll be saying that like wow you're
so beautiful oh my God okay you want a
balora and you want a not lashy eye who
no no no no no
Hey listen beauty is Skin Deep And just
because you don't have any skin doesn't
mean that your beauty is deep it means
that it's surface level which is great
actually if you think about it cuz your
beauty is right on the surface
yeah you're wasting time he's still out
there who what who is out there what do
you mean what are you talking about what
what are you what are you referring to
to me what are you referring to what
what are you referring to um okay you
want a crumbly TR of course we all do no
no no
no got it nailed it okay you want some
chica blue yeah I am chica blue on there
and there and Squad laa not good enough
it's good enough it's good enough okay
you want the lashy
left hello the lashy left okay lashy
left and I remember bora's mouth is that
was a favorite of yours for sure spatula
right hey don't be afraid of the dark
it's not so bad on my name is Mark is
this it yeah that's it okay A little bit
of chica there okay Freddy Brown on the
no no no no no
remember the goodness in your
soul okay yeah I got you hold on why did
that get that one too
okay there we go okay hold on
everything's good everything is so good
where is it okay look at me yep I am yep
I got that okay look at me here we go
okay I think that's everything you got
the brown on there the layer Brown there
on the
lips no no no no hey don't worry about a
thing nothing is
bad what
just give me that mask and get out okay
all right it's okay is there a coin in
here oh the Mas there you go there there
it's fine now leave me alone I need to
think okay I could where could he be
hiding I could pain I could paint it or
something I
could I could paint it might be a little
less
horrific what did I I
get you have a mouth there H you didn't
have a mouth before what are you trying
to hide huh okay so I just
oh well that's
convenient still horrible everything's
still horrible deplorable good to hear
it's arts and crafts
Loft okay I'm sure this will be good and
fun copy the art
exactly it's me we're talking about
guys is different you shouldn't be here
oh hi please just leave me alone oh my
God make crafts but then you need to go
okay you got it perfectly fine where I
am it's better this way uh-huh it's
safer this way
uh-huh take that oh my God okay can I
get uh one of those that's not what I
ordered I wanted that please thank you
okay that sounds like it's ticking
extremely quickly and oh my God okay all
right we got a red
ear thank you very much for that that's
helpful am I going to run out of time
here we got an
orage there and
there got a red
inner a no not that we got a green outer
and then blue on the
eyes
done it's right there what do you think
of that wow this on the thank
you oh what what just happened whoa oh
hi oh I got to do this nonsense okay all
right can I get some buttons I got need
two or three of
those
mhm okay how do I change it okay yeah
okay we got the creepy mouth
hello oh boy hey
um can I get this again okay well that's
dead I
guess okay um oh oh right
right
oh boy this okay good enough good enough
what I wait I know I no I I I don't oh
well take that and that and one of these
and one of
these That's What You Get oh God get in
there please okay thank you okay I need
to
change okay that's all terrible but I
need four of those okay gotcha and I
eventually need a bow tie oh God hey
stop stop oh my God you're creepy okay
oh God wait that's a problem oh well
Frick that's what you get run away he
running away is he running away I bet he
ran
away well
where
okay well turns out he didn't run away
turns out this one's it's kind of
hard what the freak was that bassoon you
can make crafts but then you need to go
uh-huh no not that all right whatever
Canan what is wo that's weird it's
probably
fine probably fine gray that's fun
that's very cool all right blue on the
Audi and then green on the
any and no no no that's good there
okay so what I need to do keep this in
the left this in the right only turn it
on when it needs charge it when I
don't okay there you
go okay I need googly eyes that's for no
I don't never mind that was a
mistake no bow tie get get I see you
there and then nothing there
is that what I need nope that is not
what I need okay
great okay real quick come on give me
that give it to me what are you
doing oh my God don't do
that that's what you get okay
buttons buttons buttons
everywhere
okay change that this is
fine God why is that why would that be
that way okay I need four of the arms
for
sure where are you where are you there
you are get oh no that's bad no no no no
no no no no no
no okay I got those you do have a
beak okay switch that out let me start
applying things
I know that goes
there I know that goes
there I know oh God oh God oh
God I see
you that's what you
get okay got the arms so far I've lost
an arm God damn
it thank you you're not close enough to
worry about right now
okay I need to switch that out I don't
like that laughter where is that oh I
see
you okay so I got the beak where' the
beak go did it despawn is that can that
happen is that what can happen also why
is it so long to CH oh my God are you
kidding me go
away need to get buttons all over
again what okay this is this is a little
absurd hi I'm dead aren't I ah no I'm
not I needed that yeah I think that's is
that the checkerboard
one I think it is I think it is pop yeah
that's the one put that there okay I
need big I do need the googly eyes oh
God what is
this hey
stop do
that thankfully it doesn't seem like I
have a timer
I see you up
there okay buttons are there hey wait I
got
you that's what I thought okay God I
keep forgetting I need to actually see
what I'm
doing come on are you kidding me what's
going on there
button where are you oh no that's not
good oh I'm going to run out of power
I'm going to run out of power oh there
you are ah sh I knew it I knew it I need
more buttons what was it
bottom okay there's got to be enough
come on go go go go oh I'm dead aren't I
oh no I'm not buttons ear button ear
button put that there all I need is
googly eyes I just need googly eyes did
I get no and the beak I need googly eyes
and the beak here we go
here beak googly eyes I got it
is that both yeah okay that that there
that there that there and we're
done there we're good yep we're
good thank you I know thank
you oh god oh freak me oh my God
okay go give it to me what is wrong with
you bunny ears are definitely one eyes
are one yeah eyes are
one uh-huh bunny ears need one more
bunny ear that's
wrong and then nothing else there I'm
put that there I see the bunny ear no
this please here we go change that out
where are you at give me that oh
freak okay no no no no no no no no okay
arms arms are up top I can get
those okay got
those oh
fre i l one I think and the cruel
mouth okay Co mouth last one of you okay
charge that charge that please okay
where oh
[__] I need to charge that for a bit I
think I can get the
yellow I think that's yellow but I don't
know where are you at no don't do it oh
whoops I got blue damn it I got blue
okay yellow on the
mouth blue on the right eye got it okay
I just need to charge that I just need
to take my time because there's no rush
here it doesn't seem oh
God come here you
there no no what was
that
no that's what I thought okay what am I
missing I'm missing a bow tie and I'm
missing
buttons oh there's a bow
tie is that the right bow
tie no that's not the right bow tie
unless there's no other bow
tie no that's the right bow tie and then
just buttons this is going to make me
lose my mind why is that like that go
away buttons are down there what are you
doing I'm I'm shining it right you
mother
Humper please have enough
piece I know there's buttons somewhere
on here I think that yeah I think it was
at the bottom I only need the one there
it is one button right there okay that's
all the colors or that's all the
[Music]
shapes okay where are you
at there you are doesn't seem I want to
get him there when he's there it doesn't
want to go okay I got to
know okay let that charge I see the
numbers on the side now I've got all the
shapes googly eyes everything now it's
just a matter of painting so I need the
paintbrush which is right there
okay I see
you so we need
green this eye need purple
this and that gray on the bottom is that
orange I couldn't tell if that was
orange okay he's
coming so green going for green green is
there and there
okay
orange red and yellow orange and orange
and that should that should be it
done what what do you mean what what
what what do you mean that's not what I
did what do you mean that that's not
what I
had why was it completely
wrong oh my
God whatever whatever I'll do it all
over again I
guess
I
button maybe oh is it like the
positioning on the chest wasn't right
for these things wait what no that it
just it literally just changed
everything I don't know why but it
did oh God I got to let that charge else
he's going to give me give give oh my
God oh my are you kidding
me that's what you get okay I don't
understand understand why it did it that
way but it did and whatever it's
fine okay we're
done
okay okay ears I need
that okay we got bunny
ears okay we got two bunny
ears
yes that's what we
needed there's that put that there goly
eye okay goly
eye I see
it okay just need the evil mouth oh
there's all the arms and legs but you're
supposed to be
there no
see some of the things that I had are
still
there they're just for some reason not
right
now okay so that's looking
correct I just need the evil
mouth
there it
is that's
that okay we're all
there
hello okay got
this okay we need
blue that's good blue plus yellow there
green St was green as
well okay you're
fine okay
yellow Good
yell
yep
stop okay so that should still be orange
I just need purple up there and we're
good to
go that looks right oh
oh it was supposed to be that I see
there we go now we're
done set it on the fridge get out okay
well why are you depressed about that
one but you weren't about the other ones
all right holy
heck there he is Squad aa oh he doesn't
look so bad
it looks kind of happy well all right
that'll do it for this one we've
discovered that everything is a
lie we're trapped in a reality of our
own
making willing servants to that which
shall eventually end us anything in here
coin coin coin coin damn whose hand is
that whose bottle is
that whose penis is this all right thank
you everybody so much for watching have
a lovely day and look forward to more
Five Nights at Freddy's coming very soon
check out the big ass playlist that I
got a FNAF stuff there something in
there look you and brighten
that